all of your comments are really spot on
I was really struggling when I do this
piece and my mind is going like monkey
bananas so I do like that about
critiques it's not the end of the
process the critique is the beginning of
the next part of the process Jesus
Christ it looks like a death notice
I don't know how to say a word that
really yeah there's an r in there
yeah I haven't had to say that word
since the 80s this is it's what you want
a poster to be why is it inverted is it
inverted because Virgil's dead maybe put
it in a plastic bag
oh that's a call back but I I maybe want
to do that in a second but uh I'm a
nerve I'm nervous to try
[Music]
Let's uh move on to
um is that it that is it oh my gosh
let's move on to me now
I was like I need time to prep my files
but all right three people I picked is
Patrick Kyle and Chris and so I'll show
you a little bit of the inspiration this
was the the piece that Patrick picked
and it's an interesting shirt with the
Mona Lisa and some kind of taped
elements and the stripes that we're so
used to seeing from off-white and here's
the finished poster itself which I I
think is quite attractive I want to talk
about that a little bit here are some of
the details of that poster okay so
before I was talking about the smart or
designer quotes versus the dumb quotes
or the double Prime marks and I think
you find those in the type glyph section
here right so if you go into glyphs you
can find that somewhere in here and you
can use that it's right there actually
so it's pretty easy to find it's a
little little thing for you guys to take
notice of here's what I like about this
design that you've referenced the
original design and it seems like you
really understand what was working in
terms of finding some kind of image some
kind of photographic element is this
Napoleon charging up the hill or
something I believe it is and then using
some of those elements and what I like
is that there's a a sense of some kind
of material here I think it's just
generated inside illustrator but it
feels like there's a sheet of Vellum
that has some thickness to it and it's
it's creating a different level of
contrast it's reducing the contrast in
in that shape I like the the feeling of
How It's deconstructed and there's
layers but I still have an ability to
read what's going on virgo is up front
and big and ubiquity so those are my
primary reads and it allows me to
concentrate on that and I I also like
I'm going to zoom in here at the bottom
here you can see Napoleon crossing the
Alps how there is just a some
uncomfortableness in terms of It kind of
sneaking or peeking underneath that
layer film that Vellum and I really
quite enjoy that and we can appreciate
the levels of contrast how it's lighter
gray above it and darker as a black
thing underneath I think this is a very
successful design I really enjoy this
piece and and kudos to you and I
normally wouldn't say that unless I felt
it so don't feel like you're being
cheated out of a longer critique I would
try to pick this apart more if I could
um and I don't know if I need to I'm
going to pause here and ask either
Terence or Charles if they had anything
they wanted to say about this agree I
think what's particularly interesting
about this is again kind of reducing the
contrast of that image in in relation to
how that that t-shirt or the sweatshirt
design and but also making something new
with it you didn't use the Mona Lisa
again you used a different image and
kind of the juxtaposition of his face
with the word France right above it is
is also like really powerful without
being silly I think and also how you
kind of integrated these warning Stripes
which can which could be overpowering
for the whole composition but the way
that that you layered them in they don't
overpower it so it feels well balanced
uh overall I think there's a what became
a sort of Maxim for me as a as a teacher
was that in a group of 15 students
there's bound to be one who you don't
really need to help at all so you end up
talking about things like spacing
spacing of type like you know you could
actually the space between Virgil and
ablo could be tightened up a little bit
and of course you're you know you're
you're tabular figures are drifting but
you know these are small things compared
to the overall sort of Triumph of the
composition my biggest want in this
composition in addition to you know just
give me 20 minutes with you to go over
every single thing that needs to be
fixed in the spacing of the type besides
those things is I want to see it
animated like I want it I want to see
this poster influx I want to see it do
what posters are doing now which is to
not sit still because I think it's it's
an open invitation based on the way that
you've you've constructed it here and
designed it for it to be in construction
actually as a relate I didn't say that
on purpose but it's in fact it was a
slip of the ton but I think it's apropos
to deconstruct it through animation
would be really incredibly powerful I
think yeah Space Between The Virgil and
the ablo space between the one the nine
the space between the two and the one
the extra space between lvmh and
off-white at the top maybe bumping up
the end Dash a little bit in height the
space before the Ampersand on the left
hand side between and breaking maybe the
space between breaking and boundaries
all of those could just get tightened up
a slight bit and I say that because the
spacing of the type generally fairly
tight the letter spacing so the word
spacing should follow suit and that will
just it's not going to make this poster
tremendously better it's a great poster
but it will it will add that layer of
Polish to the end of it that will you
know sort of put it in a in an elite
class I think this poster gets a lot of
the different principles that we've been
talking about right in in terms of
creating very Dynamic spaces if you look
at the block of white copy here and over
here the proportions feel really good
there's a good Cadence and flow to how
you're moving things around the page you
notice the strong vertical line that's
happening along this grid line it's not
directly in the center it's in the
center and the shift over to the left
and this box here it's kind of it feels
like it's been cut off and it gets
repeated over here so there's a lot of
dynamic things that are going on that
allow an element of motif a component to
repeat and and create a certain Rhythm
to it I also also really like these like
this horizontal line This vertical line
and notice Patrick just didn't run all
the way across and and so it creates a
lot more visual interest when you're
able to do that so all of you who had
had struggled with just creating too
many elements and not knowing what to to
feature and what to to hero up this is a
good example of that where there's not
too many tricks applied to the type
itself so that other things can work
otherwise it would be so overwhelming
and I also like the the changes in point
size for drawable is is the biggest and
going down to the deconstruction and
breaking boundaries and then to Paris
and United States so kind of mostly like
three point sizes observing that rule
for the most part and that's probably a
clue I think there's a fourth Point size
in here or so but it looks like there's
three primary Point sizes and it works
really well really well done any last
thoughts before I move on to the next
person quite beautiful Patrick any
response to that okay guys I just want
to thank for the critique I think it's
Australian point and yeah okay now we'll
go to Kyle Kyle's inspiration is this
shoe which I hadn't seen before or and I
think it's really cool with the Deep
Magento or purple color and and the kind
of splattered paint these really like
intense colors here and and to contrast
against the helmetic or just flush left
type this is Kyle's uh finished poster
and there's some effect applied to this
where it feels curved and I quite like
it and here here's the poster as a I
think the flattened piece but a detail
to it really neat so this is Kyle's work
here and I'm going to zoom in or zoom
out a little bit okay when we talk about
design and allowing things to breathe
this is the exact opposite approach
there's so much that's going on here and
at first when I open up this file it's
like let me get into the thing it's a
couple hundred layers deeper stuff and
so I'm not going to even pretend to like
go into this and mess around and there's
there's so much going on and usually my
reaction to this would be like I don't
like it but there's there's something
that you're doing here where because
your your use of color and big shapes
like this off-white across this black
band with the stitching on it I'll
allows things to still to to come up
from the background so it doesn't feel
like complete noise and I can't figure
out what's going on I think there's some
some kind of maximalism in terms of your
design approach that I really like you
know generally speaking I don't love it
when people stretch type like in the
word ubiquity here I think it's okay I I
don't think you need to do it but maybe
it was your desire to have a much more
condensed typeface to break out from
everything else but a good use of like
color and repeating that like with these
zip ties that are around their shoe so
you're using that same chartreuse I
don't know how to say a word that really
yeah there's an r in there yeah yeah I
haven't had to say that word since the
80s so and then using just a simple bold
Sans serif type face with a little bit
of this spray painted wood like here at
the bottom left hand corner there's
something that's really nice about this
and all the halftone patterns that
you're using in here and even using a
little bit of that photoshop language
which is the transparency grid built
into it perhaps that was intentional or
sometimes you get fake pngs on the web
and you just pull them in and hey it
works also the barcode at the bottom
here is really nice perhaps some of
these elements aren't as nice but in in
the larger schema thing that it works
for me Terence what about you yeah I
think we've seen
um you know examples today of both
minimalism and maximalism and I think
both of those approaches can be more
difficult than something in between yeah
I think executing those two Styles
successfully is they're difficult in
different ways but again kind of the the
hierarchy and the focus kind of needs to
be nailed uh in order to make it work
and I do love the the richness of this
and how it's kind of cleverly using all
of the black and white stuff to allow it
to to go back so actually you know the
intense colors are is really you know
become the the focal points to bounce
around with but I think the most
successful kind of combination is kind
of towards the upper left corner where
we're getting a combination of something
where it says off-white on that black
strip there that kind of quadrant of the
poster feels the best to me maybe just
because I get a little bit of breathing
space to focus on on that that headline
right there so that feels kind of like
the best use of maximalism and
functioning as a poster quickly Charles
what about you I really enjoy it it
reminds me you know when I was in high
school I used to do the the signs for
school dances and stuff like that and
we'd roll out a big piece of paper and
just do giant lettering and brush
painting we are doing one about uh
School cleanup so for the beginning of
the day we we coated this piece of paper
with glue and then emptied all the waste
baskets onto it then left the room to
come back in the afternoon to paint over
top of it because there's nothing like
the sort of busyness of a ground of
incredibly chaotic stuff to create focal
interest in something that has Clarity
so off-white Virgil ablo the shape of
the shoe use and then that giant Punchy
ubiquity down in the bottom they each
get their power from sort of
semi-randomness and Chaos at the
background which is pure joy to sort of
like swim in and out of you're anchored
by these things that the composition
wants you to pay attention to that are
brought to the fore that are painted on
Top This is and in this particular
framing as I'm seeing it in Photoshop
right now with the dark gray background
it's what you want a poster to be like
full of focal interest and complete
contrast with what's going on behind it
you know you're a much more creative
person in high school than I was I would
just say that I got in big trouble for
that one that's why it's stuck you know
that that idea that you're talking about
about just getting a giant roll of paper
and laying it on the floor and and
gluing a bunch of objects together
probably would be the way to do
something like this I could see this as
a as a really cool window display and
it's just as a backdrop to something
that lives in front so if you were to
collect a bunch of found materials
things that were discarded envelopes
scraps of packaging and you were to
assemble them them together and then to
wash them all down with like a just
paint them all white or something to
create a really interesting backdrop to
then add other objects and and to pull
things out from that I think that would
be really cool so when you describe that
Charles that's what I envisioned and I
was just thinking man my my mind just
opened up even more like what the
possibilities are this is a wonderful
digital collage here with some really
cool components to it but this is also
an opportunity for you to do something
in the future maybe not for this project
but maybe for one of your clients or
something when they would be brave
enough to try this with you the sheets
of acetate with halftone patterns so old
discarded magazines but you pick those
because there was something really cool
about the shape or the color and just
adding that on I just think that this is
cool this were like dimensional and real
it would be even like crazier in my
opinion Kyle are you here did you want
to say anything I am just grateful for
you guys and like feeling like this is a
successful execution this is my first
collage so I've struggled and I got some
help from some alumni of the type
geography a one class
um we pulled our resources and our
brains together and they helped me kind
of push this over so um I wasn't sure
how it would be
you jumped in the pool yes you did he
went all in and then he didn't have a
bathing suit and he's like can you guys
see me or what and I love to hear that
the the alumni or other people from the
topography or one course came together I
didn't know that you kept in touch with
people but that's really freaking
awesome I love to hear I love hearing
that thank you very much Kyle last but
not least is Chris Herrera so Chris's
inspiration is this shoe which is uh
just white on white with some simple
typography on it and here's what Chris
came up with and and this is a poster
mock-up I believe and there's something
intriguing When You See It tiled up like
this there's more that's going on but
what we want to do is we want to zero
and we want to focus in on your finished
poster and it looks like that and here's
some some of the details now Chris also
sent along some of the elements that he
used it seemed like he was printing
things out and then really playing
around with it messing around with the
breaking down with probably chemicals or
something so that the type starts to
bleed you can until just by looking at
this image and don't make a liar out of
me that this was not done digitally this
was photographed back and brought back
into Photoshop for composite when I
looked at all the elements that you sent
along with this I think there was so
much more there that you could have used
if you allowed those elements to be the
star right now my eye goes to this
inverted image of the shoe which you
which is strange because the inspiration
was a white and white shoe with some
simple lettering and then you've
inverted it and now that's where my eye
goes and and that's the least
interesting part to me is the photograph
of the shoe itself I'm afraid like I
don't know where it is for me to even
try and turn it off but I think if you
were to get rid of that I think then it
would give you so much more space to
play around with the rest of your design
it's some interesting and odd choices in
terms of like how many different point
sizes you're using here deconstruction
and breaking boundaries there it's
increasing in size and it seems like
it's kind of like 1 one idea and and I
think there was one that you did it was
simpler where where it was just flush
left and one like it wasn't tilted in
space like this generally speaking if
you tilt things in space like this
you're drawing my eye in off of the
bottom right corner into the left part
but then it's banking over here to the
right it doesn't seem like there's great
intentionality behind why you're doing
that I don't personally totally
understand that and I think if you just
kept this a little bit simpler but use
that same effect of the distress type I
think that's a wonderful thing to do to
add a tactile quality to your design
some other things that you're doing here
in terms of like repeating off-white to
the right here I just don't love because
it feels like it's a afterthought or a
throwaway element and it's trapping some
white space between the photograph and
the edge of this so just again repeating
edges and trapping space generally
speaking not a great thing to do and
just jamming things in the corners you
can see again following the edge and
then this this stripe tape at the bottom
but there is something that's really
cool here I I do like this because I've
seen this in a bit of Virgil's work is
that stitching to the thing that holds
things together now generally speaking
this looks like tape so tape doesn't
need to be held together so this is
somewhat redundant but I do like that
idea where it could be more powerful is
to use the stitching to hold something
that is actually dimensional and feels
like it has to be fastened to the
original backing of this poster in order
for it not to fall away I think that's
where you're going to get maximum play
out of something like this so good on
you for picking up that element but
perhaps you can use it in in a more
creative way there a simple trick for
for a few of you is to create the
illusion of depth is to make things not
parallel to the plane like you can see
that the vertical and the horizontal
dimensions of the page are observed here
whereas the tape it's not parallel to
that so it starts to feel much more
dimensional and so if you were to take
this and like make it a little bit off
kilter or to to have it Bend up in space
it's going to create that sense of
dimensionality and it'll come off the
page a little bit more and that's kind
of what you want to do I do like this
repetition of ubiquity I I don't love
how it's placed or or how it's used but
just maybe as an idea of repeating it
over and over again Charles talked about
the right quote marks or the wrong quote
marks to use here and just repeating
that some other things that I would love
for you to think about a little bit more
is about how all these elements on the
page work with each other and and right
now I'm not feeling that and usually
just observing some grid lines will help
you're doing here there's a grid line
here and you're pulling it down here
there's one here but how do they all
play with each other that's the part
that I'm missing from this now generally
speaking when color is being used I like
it when it's more of that brilliant
color that off-white and Virgil's known
for like the Brilliant Orange
what do they call it zip ties or it's
just like that punch of color like the
previous design those things tend to pop
versus using more of this muted color
over to you Terence yeah I'll repeat to
it you know the breaking boundaries
headline that's that's uh distorted and
re-imaged is the most successful part
and I think that's really well done I do
think it competes with the the image of
the shoes just because they're so so big
and so dark and then the bright orange
ubiquity ubiquity stack in the middle
that creates that focal point there so I
wish it were you know rearranged in a
different way so that the the text and
that you know that nice distorted uh
image had a little bit more power to it
I do like the the elements with the
orange tape and again I wish the
stitching were you know larger you can
you could exaggerate it especially when
it's in this kind of digital realm but
the the stack of orange ubiquity also
kind of reminds me of how you know
stitching would work in a kind of a
repeating pattern so there's a good idea
there that wasn't fully expanded but you
have a good beginning here I think I
could see it improving with other you
know revisions and stuff the thing that
bothers me is again you kind of like
adding more text than you need there's a
us you know a second kind of paragraph
there with the his design language we're
kind of adding more stuff and I think it
doesn't feel like it supports this as an
event poster it's like all of this focus
is on is on the shoe and and the
headline and all of this other stuff
about the actual show is just so
diminished it's almost like they're just
tucked away in the corner as if they're
on the edge of your desk they don't feel
integrated in with the the rest of the
design so it feels a little bit
incomplete because of those little tiny
things just kind of tucked away they
don't feel as considered as all the
other parts you spent a lot you spend
all this time on making that nice
headline and none of the time on the on
the little pieces you know so yeah I
think you have two posters here two
really good posters
they're in one right now I think the
idea of inverting the the white shoe is
is is incredible but it's being
torpedoed by this beautiful
deconstructed type down at the bottom
left I mean they're two it's like you
know Battle of the the Miss universes or
something like that like two great
things that if they if they just went
back to their own respective countries
would be awe-inspiring yeah and even go
in further I mean just take ubiquity as
the yeah see now we're living in a space
and there's this that's just the tip of
the iceberg what I was thinking is if
you if you cut this poster in half and
took the bottom half and turned it on
its side you'd have a great poster which
would be you know unexpectedly on its
side so type running either top to
bottom or bottom to top unexpectedly
large in its scale unexpectedly broken
in its form it would just be an
incredible thing unto itself and
something that would dominate a space if
you walked in and then the same thing
with the shoe if you're just living in
my dream
like Okay computer now I wanted to
okay yeah the alternate there and then
we're back to um ten and a half on 16.
like all the other type is just 10 and a
half on 16 and you're golden you are
golden Christopher the next one is just
uh the ubiquity I mean the the black
rectangle blown up to the size of the
entire thing with the tape over the
edges and everything keep it warts and
all maybe put it in a plastic bag
it's a call back but I I maybe want to
do that in a second but uh I'm a nerve
I'm nervous to try so let's see what
happens because conceptually that is
that's beautiful it begs questions why
is it inverted is it inverted because
Virgil's Dead He's left us too soon to
post her about his our loss or is it
that it's subverting expectations the
shoes are white I've made them black
look at it
let me go find some plastic bag I'll be
right back slip the whole thing into a
plastic bag staple it to the wall and
photograph that and then put that on
first that's a cool image it's
unexpected it's arresting it's it
creates questions and then that ubiquity
gets just got framed like that in the
upper left it just happened to show off
there I mean Chris put it there man oh
you can be impossible yeah I I do have
plastic putting in the bag let's see
what happens if we just screen this over
and see not quite inside the plastic bag
but there is some plastic quality to it
now it's the idea of seeing seeing a
poster in a Ziploc bag like in the
middle of a French Palace
that's the it's like what is this doing
here that's his play over and over again
and I feel like you're getting some of
that with the way that you've treated
this Christopher you've created an
unexpected situation for us which is
great so what you just did here Charles
I think what we hope all of you will
think about in the future which is to
step away from your design and pretend
like it's not yours and to really play
with it and focus in on what the
elements are that you have that you like
I didn't like the inverted photo Charles
liked it and he found a way to make it
work and so let's go through the steps
here without even changing any design
really we haven't changed anything all
we did was crop in and because we're
like there's just too much that's going
on so the first iteration of this is
just to take what you have which is this
beautiful type and let it be their hero
and we're we're seeing this theme over
and over as we're going through
everyone's critique which is there's
just so much going on and you need to
make that decision to be a really good
editor is probably to be a really good
designer and there's some happy
accidents that happen that when I places
and cropped it in you can see that the
leftover image from the bottom adds just
enough of visual interest there
otherwise it might be a little bit
boring and it's it's losing some of the
off-whiteness of Virgil's aesthetic and
then Charles immediately recognized
perhaps there's two posters and either
one can work and then we went to this
just simple type a little bit of the
information and then allowing the image
to be the hero and whether you like a
plastic or not it adds something is
probably not the perfect execution of it
but you can see it creates a certain
texture to it and it adds some
dimensionality to it Charles any any
final thoughts on this design before we
we get Chris into this conversation one
other thing I mean in in terms of
following on the theme of killing Your
Darlings you can you can use your
Incredible typographic Shrinking Ray on
any piece of text there's no reason that
any of the stuff that was part of the
brief for this project couldn't be set
in six point type you can make it go to
the bottom you can make it go onto the
top of the hill three miles away you can
make that type really small and
concentrate on the things that you want
to be most apparent and most important I
didn't remember seeing anything in the
Mandate about microtype right no you can
no problem
no no type can be too big and no type
can be too small when you're in the
driver's seat so yeah feel free to deep
six it's a bunch of type in order to
create the compositional focus that you
seek wonderful is Chris here he's here
right with us I'm watching him oh you
are okay there we are I'm just very
thankful you know I've been watching you
guys for many years so this is my first
time submitting anything uh typography
is something that I I really want to get
better at so I'm just really thankful to
hear the the critiques and I'm gonna
definitely go back to the lab and I'll
take everything you guys have said and
and you know give it another go so I'm
just very thankful wonderful glad to
hear that you're in uh isana encouraged
and potentially inspired to go and do
this and continue your your journey as a
designer each and every one of these
critiques is our Our Hope for you is to
be able to take away something from this
and just send continue to build upon
that as you have hopefully a lifetime
and career in design uh one one last
thing I just noticed is as I was scaling
this image up per Charles suggestion is
that you could you can start to pick up
the texture a little bit more and it
starts to feel more organic instead of
when we're we're zoomed all the way out
we can't always see and appreciate all
those things so just think about that
too and be open to the Happy accidents
you can easily crop scale scale up or
scale down and just block out an idea if
it works and if the resolution falls
apart you can always go back and rebuild
it and and to be as free with this
because pixels are free you can do
anything you want and you can play so we
want to encourage all of you to do that
I think we're at that point in time that
we are done and surprisingly we had
budgeted exactly two and a half hours
for this and look at this gentlemen we
have four minutes to spare how
incredible is that it's so good time
though we could show the a couple of the
other uh submissions just to feature
them here okay let's do that and then
and then and before we wrap I I
definitely want to thank uh our two
distinguished guests here so Mark go
ahead and take it over show us some of
the other designs so here you go we've
got a few submissions here we've got one
from Stephen helterbrand Rob Farrelly
Jerry fascio and Stephen Tang so this is
page 102. I don't know if you guys want
to make any comments on this and then
we've got another one from sangharsh
jadav Nur Majid and Eric Beach so again
thank you for everybody who submitted um
you know it was a hard choice for
everybody and we know we wanted to get
through at least three uh from each
designer or from each critique here okay
I want to thank all of you for
submitting your work I know this was a
challenging thing and it's one thing for
us as instructors or people who are
reviewing your work to give you our
opinion on things and it's a whole other
thing to actually be the person is put
your heart and soul into trying to solve
a problem also juggling whatever busy
life you may or may not have with work
with your your personal obligations as
well as your professional obligation so
we do appreciate you we're always was a
little scared because we don't know what
we're going to get it's like Life's a
box of chocolates and we just have no
idea what you're going to come up with
and we're so glad that you participated
in this and I also want to just share a
profound sincere thanks to monotype for
loaning both of you to us uh Terence for
you coming on board and bringing that
critique sandwich with you bringing in
the kindness and it felt like it
balanced out the tartness of everything
else so that was really wonderful and
and Charles for bringing that super
specific language and just dropping
terms that we're gonna have to look up
afterwards and just helping me to learn
about end dashes and then mdashes
muttons and all kinds of other stuff
what was the end standing for what does
the n stand for again not not I thought
it was something much more complicated
than not no they could have chosen
anything even net would have been better
than nut and money but you know there
you go there you are but maybe because
it's so weird that we'll we'll remember
it because sometimes that's what happens
right for all of you that are here live
staying up late I don't know what hour
in the morning it is for some of you or
deep into the night thank you very much
thank you for pulling on to the side of
the road and talking to us and not
getting into an accident so all of you
thank you very much okay that's it for
us Mark take us out of here I think
that's a wrap see you guys next time see
you in the future